[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic la force de coriolis dans notre
univers les objets se déplacent
naturellement en ligne droite et à
vitesse constante
lorsqu'un objet ne subit aucune force
il n'a aucune raison de tourner ou de
changer de vitesse et va donc conserver
son mouvement
lorsqu'on se projette dans le futur de
l'humanité
on peut imaginer concevoir un jour des
voyages de longue durée dans l'espace
pour permettre à des astronautes de
vivre pendant plusieurs mois
il nous faudra très certainement
concevoir des systèmes pour simuler la
gravité dans nos vaisseaux nos corps y
étant habitué sur terre
l'une des solutions les plus simples et
les plus prometteuses et celle de la
centrifugeuse une grande roue en
rotation sur elle-même dans laquelle la
force centrifuge repousserait les
astronautes vers la paroi leur donnant
ainsi une impression de gravité
cherchons d'abord à comprendre l'origine
de la force centrifuge qui maintient les
astronautes contre la paroi
pour cela il suffit d'observer la
situation depuis l'extérieur lorsque la
roue tourne
elle entraîne l'astronaute dans son
mouvement
[Musique]
s'il saisit une balle dans sa main la
balle décrit un cercle
car elle est tenue par l'astronaute qui
lui-même tourner avec la roue
si l'astronaute lâche la balle celle ci
n'est plus soumise à aucune force et
elle va donc conserver son mouvement et
se déplacer en ligne droite jusqu'à
atteindre la paroisse de notre point de
vue la balle s'est simplement déplacé en
ligne droite mais pour l'astronaute qui
tourne elle lui a semblé tomber vers la
paroi il a l'impression qu'elle a subi
une force imaginaire c'est l'effet
centrifuge il est important de
comprendre que la force centrifuge n'est
pas réellement une force fondamentale
dans l'univers quand on observe la
situation depuis l'extérieur
on comprend que la balle n'a subi aucune
action une fois lâchés elle n'est plus
en contact avec l'astronaute et se
déplace donc tout droit sans accélérer
mais en l'observant tout en tournant sur
lui même
l'astronaute a l'impression qu'il existe
une force supplémentaire fictive la
force centrifuge qu'il invente pour
pouvoir comprendre le mouvement de la
balle dans son référentiel
[Musique]
imaginons désormais que notre
astronautes lance la balle vers le haut
comme avant une fois qu'il l'a lâché la
balle se déplace en ligne droite jusqu'à
rencontrer la paroisse de la roue mais
pour l'astronaute la balle quitte sa
main ralenti et retombe par l'effet
centrifuge
mais elle semble également légèrement
déviée car elle retombe devant ses pieds
et s'il l'a lancé encore plus haut
celle-ci retomberez encore plus loin de
son point de vue la seule force
centrifuge ne suffit pas à comprendre le
mouvement de la balle il lui faut
inventer une autre force fictives pour
expliquer pourquoi la balle est déviée
quand elle est en mouvement
c'est la force de coriolis
pour bien comprendre les faits coriolis
observons la situation depuis
l'extérieur lorsque la route tourne
chaque point qui la composent décrit un
cercle
ces cercles sont d'autant plus rapide
que le point en question est éloignée du
centre car il doit décrire une
trajectoire plus longue
lorsque l'astronaute tient la balle dans
sa main celle-ci parcours l'un de ces
cercles à la vitesse appropriée
mais quand il la lance vers le haut la
balle va se rapprocher de l' axe de
rotation
ici elle devrait tourner moins vite pour
suivre la roue mais comme elle a
conservé sa vitesse initiale plus rapide
la balle se déplace plus vite que la
roue et elle va par conséquent prendre
de l'avancé et finir par retomber devant
l'astronaute en lançant la balle vers le
haut l'astronaute la rapprocher de l'axé
central
à cet endroit la balle se déplace plus
vite que la roue et va donc prendre de
l'avancé sur sa rotation ce qui semble
la dévier vu de l'intérieur
de façon analogue
l'astronaute ressentent également
l'effet coriolis dans son propre corps
sa tête étant plus proche du centre ses
pieds se déplace plus vite
il ressent sa rotation et risque des
nausées et une perte d'équilibré si l'on
souhaite exploiter ce genre de
centrifugeuses à l'avenir il sera donc
nécessaire qu'elle soit suffisamment
large pour que l'effet coriolis ils
soient négligeables sur le corps des
passagers
[Musique]
tout comme la force centrifuge la force
de coriolis apparaît dès lors qu'on
observe une situation en tournant il
peut s'agir d'une centrifugeuse mais
aussi d'un manège et même de notre
planète tout entière
la terre tourne en effet sur elle-même
au rythme d'une rotation par jour à sa
surface
nous sommes entraînés par sa rotation et
les objets qui sont proches des pôles
tourne moins vite que ceux qui sont
proches de l'équateur
l'effet coriolis va donc intervenir à
l'échelle de la planète
par exemple si on imagine un projectile
lancé dans l'atmosphère du fait que la
terre tourne en dessous du projectile la
trajectoire qu'il trace sur la surface
va nous sembler courbet comme la balle
dans la centrifugeuse
le projectile se déplacent tout droit
mais on mesure sa trajectoire en
tournant avec la terre ce qui déforme
son apparence de façon similaire les
faits coriolis s'applique également à la
circulation des masses d'air dans
l'atmosphère et explique pourquoi les
ouragans tourner dans un sens dans
l'hémisphère nord et dans le sens opposé
dans l'hémisphère sud
[Musique]
les masses d'air qui circulent à
l'équateur se déplace plus vite que
celles qui circulent plus proche des
pôles quand les vents remonte depuis
l'équateur vers des latitudes plus
élevées
ils conservent leur vitesse initiale et
vont donc prendre de l'avancé sur la
rotation de la terre cette avance se
traduit par une rotation des vents dans
l'atmosphère ce qui explique le sens
dans lequel tourne les ouragans
[Musique]
en restant sur terre l'effet coriolis va
également modifier notre perception du
poids la force centrifuge qui provient
de la rotation de la planète a pour
effet de nous repousser de son axe de
rotation est de diminuer légèrement
notre poids en s'opposant à la gravité
si la terre tournait plus vite la force
centrifuge seraient plus élevés et nous
serions plus léger al'inverse si la
planète tournait plus lentement la force
centrifuge serait plus faible et la
gravité se ferait davantage ressentir
[Musique]
imaginons un train qui se déplace à
l'équateur de la planète
lorsque le train roule vers l'est
il tourne sur la surface dans le même
sens que la rotation de la terre par
addition de son mouvement avec celui de
la planète
le train tourne plus vite que la surface
et ressent donc une force centrifuge
plus élevé en se déplaçant vers l'est
le train est donc plus léger corpo de
façon opposée
s'ils se déplaçait maintenant vers
l'ouest sa vitesse s'opposerait à la
rotation de la terre ils iraient en
quelque sorte à contre courant par
rapport à la surface et la force
centrifuge qu'il ressent serait plus
faible
le train serait plus lourd qu'au repos
on appelle ce phénomène étrange
les faits eux josh il s'agit d'un cas
particulier de l'effet coriolis qui nous
montre que le poids des objets sur terre
dépend de leur mouvement
[Musique]
pour conclure la force de coriolis n'est
pas une vraie force
il s'agit d'un effet d'inertie qui
apparaît lorsqu'on mesure une
trajectoire depuis un point de vue en
rotation lorsqu'un corps se déplace dans
un référentiel qui tourne on a
l'impression qu'il subit une force la
force de coriolis qui courbent
progressivement sa trajectoire
introduire les faits coriolis comme une
force permet d'étudier les mouvements
dans une centrifugeuse les trajectoire
balistique des objets dans l'atmosphère
la circulation des vents et ouragans ou
encore le poids d'un objet qui se
déplace sur terre mais l'effet coriolis
permet également de comprendre les
vibrations de certaines molécules qui
tourne sur elle même
les techniques de vol utilisés par
certains insectes comme les mouches
l'existence de points de stabilité dans
le système solaire et laure bits de
certains astres en forme de fer à cheval
ou même le comportement des fluides et
des vortex au sein des disques
protoplanétaires dans lesquelles se
forment de nouvelles exoplanètes et des
disque d'accrétion qui se forme autour
des trous noirs supermassifs
[Musique]